what did you say I don't know
hey guys what's up so Jen and I have
decided that we're gonna do beta which
is vlog every day in August it's going
to be actually vlogging everyday it's
gonna be called a video every day
because I've got a couple of cooking
videos for you guys and you know
vlogging sometimes I don't do anything
or I'm doing a lot of stuff and I
actually forget to film I want to show
you guys these cupcakes don't about
cupcakes they are they're called cookies
yes
they're called cookies that I got for my
friend Matt he loves he loves the
Steelers
happy birthday Matt and that's not a
object nadeshot Matt but his birthday is
also gonna be celebrated how do I make
him Andrea I brought wine ones to my
trick I feel like you have a flood cuz
it's weird
oh that's how the goodness no it's nice
yeah it doesn't come out very bad
because we also have a walk-in later
hint water kids big spoon yeah just
arrow II think maybe we forget some
fruity vodka yeah okay sangria tomorrow
turnout I'm just feeling so domestic I'm
gonna make Jenna breakfast because she's
so scary
no what did you say I quoted you what
did you say wrong so everyone eggs it's
true and it's true I'm gonna use this
for a tripod okay right this is a
recommendation from Francesca and it's
actually changed my life honey 101 of
them I forgot I was vlogging the eggs
but this is how I'm making is gonna be
the best scrambled egg in your life
that's good it's good we don't want to
taste like no this is the technique
I think I'm looking pretty good actually
you think Jen I'm thinking this vlog is
going to be a combination of the sangria
and this party today because I didn't
know anything actually other Matt's
party sure
oops the magic salt sorry I was like
filming your crotch so their little
flakes are out put them on for you oh
wow look at that oh my mom
oh yeah exactly basically the best halt
ever yeah
thanks for Jessica look at this we got
Matt's birthday card great her do you
know what time it is it's time for your
birthday Bunney
oh nothing inside rules to our friend
Matt should you label the balls okay we
had a label or two we've got minecraft
heads why did you put your Minecraft
necklace on I less Matt wants to wear it
Mac look at you look at you room room
room room I'm going to just go over on
my my area and do all the things that
you need to do on foot I make my oatmeal
I do my laundry on this I get my lunch
whatever I need to do downstairs you're
gonna be like the wall-e characters have
you seen wall-e cut right here can you
alright I'm real busy printing Miley I
want to try it oh and you got this yeah
look how fast
I'll get something got some explaining
to do just get off it's fun isn't it
when you fall down No Oh Matt take a
peek at your cake all right can I use
one these knives can I use it on the
hoverboard yep book careful I wouldn't
no way what are you doing you can't beat
you can't do that you can't be lifting
it like that okay all right leave me
alone you guys doing I may not be a
smart man but I know what cake is oh my
god are you guys kidding me and you get
it
it's a Minecraft right yes a minecraft
cake it looks / oh my god that's what
that is
yeah it's the cake that is amazing I
don't even make that well Wow look at
that cake looks great looks great you
look great what I can't believe that
babe what's wrong
zum-zum you gotta get emotional Josh huh
Oh big went out when you go like to one
series it everything wrong - well you
guys witnessing as I am Wow this is the
phase and finally finish up I'll begin a
nomination finish in two three it looks
so amazing school I love it actually
thanks Jess well hold off her happy
birthday it's a little puppy you also
drinks oh don't really drink it it is
getting okay mana over her off its Kate
like what is going on
like I'm terrified because if you just
assume the horse put these on and then
this is starts moving that [__] start
to go on those things go so fast
I believe they go about 12 miles an hour
which is pretty quick we make it in
charge though but I have an emergency
okay move dog get out the way they love
this is it coolest see don't do it
all right here we go all right what you
got you got to play around with a knife
doodoo trouble tonight
oh my bed wait are you on the monitor
over no she's not she's not with the
butcher knife yeah okay get wedged in
your sternum don't do that you know I
think she's fine cut the
I'm trying man yeah I gotta get them
clean cream um like it hit me great are
you the first thing to kind of cake on
my rubber yeah - you're way too weight
to bolster shall I serve the cake up
serve it up
each piece - top recording because no
one likes this anymore
come on pork to get you manatee guys
buddy that says anything different is
blind this is my camp without win I know
I took a bunch of really great uh bull
rides tonight so I'll show you some of
those now that's it Jay Farber beta
who's that
what do we want to go hello